quand j'étais chez moi à m'occuper de mes quatre enfants en bas âge.
Donc j'avais peur d'aller en entretien
et de me mettre à parler d'une entreprise qui n'existait plus.
Alors je me suis réabonnée au Wall Street Journal
et l'ai lu d'un bout à l'autre pendant six mois
avant de me sentir suffisamment informée sur l'état du monde des affaires.
Je suis convaincue que les redécolleurs sont un diamant brut.
Et voici pourquoi.
Pensez à notre situation :
ceux d'entre nous qui sont partis pour s'occuper de leurs enfants
ne prendront plus ou peu de congés maternité.
On a déjà donné.
Nous avons moins besoin de déménager pour suivre un conjoint ;
nous sommes plus installés dans la vie.
Nous avons une grande expérience du travail.
Nous avons un point de vue plus mature.
Nous n'essayons pas de nous trouver, aux dépens d'un employeur.
Et nous avons l'énergie, l'envie de retourner au travail,
justement parce que nous n'avons pas travaillé pendant longtemps.
D'un autre côté, j'ai discuté avec les employeurs,
et voici ce qui les dissuade
d'embaucher des redécolleurs.
D'abord, ils s'inquiètent que les redécolleurs
ne sachent plus utiliser la technologie.
Je peux vous assurer,
car je suis moi-même passée par là,
que c'est une situation temporaire.
Mon analyse financière remonte si loin, que j'ai utilisé Lotus 1-2-3.
Je ne sais pas si certains s'en souviennent,
mais j'ai dû tout réapprendre sur Excel.
Ce n'était en fait pas si difficile. Beaucoup de fonctions sont les mêmes.
PowerPoint m'a posé beaucoup plus de problèmes,
mais je l'utilise tout le temps.
Je préviens les redécolleurs que les employeurs attendent d'eux
une connaissance de base des logiciels bureautiques.
Et s'ils ne sont pas à la hauteur,
c'est à eux d'y remédier.
Et ils le font.
La deuxième inquiétude des employeurs vis à vis des redécolleurs
est qu'ils ne sachent pas ce qu'ils veulent faire.
Je dis aux redécolleurs qu'ils ont besoin de travailler dur
pour découvrir si leurs intérêts et talents ont changé ou non
pendant leur césure.
Ce n'est pas le rôle de l'employeur.
Il est de la responsabilité du redécolleur de montrer à l'employeur
ce qu'il peut apporter à l'entreprise.
En 2010, je me suis rendu compte de quelque chose.
Depuis 2008, je suivais la progression de programmes de retour à l'emploi
et en 2010, j'ai réalisé
qu'on utilisait les emplois précaires,
que ce soit un stage ou non,
mais semblable à un stage,
comme moyen pour les professionnels de retourner à l'emploi.
J'ai vu Goldman Sachs et Sara Lee
mettre en place des programmes de réinsertion professionnelle.
J'ai vu un ingénieur redécolleurs, candidat peu commun à la réinsertion,
postuler pour un stage dans l'armée,
et, plus tard, pour un emploi permanent.
J'ai vu deux universités rendre les stages obligatoires
pour les programmes de formation de mi-carrière.
J'ai écrit un essai sur ce que je voyais,
c'est devenu un article pour le Harvard Business Review
appelé « Le stagiaire quarantenaire ».
L'honneur revient aux éditeurs pour le titre,
et pour cette image
sur laquelle on peut voir un quarantenaire parmi les étudiants.
Puis, merci Fox Business News,
qui a appelé le concept « Le stagiaire cinquantenaire ».
(Rires)
Donc cinq des plus grandes entreprises financières
offrent des stages pour les financiers qui retournent au travail.
Et aujourd'hui, des centaines de personnes ont déjà participé.
Ces stages sont rémunérés,
et les gens qui passent ensuite à des postes permanents
sont des cadres de premier ordre.
Et maintenant, sept des plus grandes entreprises d'ingénierie
mènent des programmes de stages pour ingénieurs de retour
dans le cadre d'une initiative en accord avec la Society of Women Engineers.
Alors, pourquoi les entreprises proposent ces stages ?
Parce que ces stages permettent à l'employeur
d'embaucher du personnel qu'il connaît déjà,
plutôt que de faire passer une série d'entretiens.
Et puis, il n'a pas besoin de prendre une décision définitive
avant la fin du stage.
Cette période de probation diminue les risques
que certains managers associent aux redécolleurs.
Et ces stages attirent d'excellents candidats
qui s'avèrent faire de très bons employés.
Pensez au chemin parcouru.
Avant, la plupart des employeurs ne souhaitaient pas du tout
embaucher des redécolleurs.
Mais maintenant, non seulement on crée de nouveaux programmes
à l'intention des redécolleurs,
mais il est même impossible aux autres
de postuler à ce programme.
C'est un vrai signe de changement,
une vraie transformation institutionnelle,
car, si on peut résoudre le problème des redécolleurs,
on peut le résoudre pour d'autres personnes en réorientation.
En fait, un employeur vient de me dire
que leurs programmes pour les anciens combattants
s'appuient sur les mêmes programmes.
Il n'y a aucune raison de ne pas créer des programmes pour retraités.
Un public différent, un même concept.
Et voici ce qui est arrivé à Tracy Shapiro.
Vous vous souvenez qu'elle devait dire à tout le monde
qu'elle voulait reprendre le travail.
Eh bien, une conversation avec un autre parent de son quartier
lui a obtenu une offre d'emploi.
Pour un poste de comptable dans un département financier.
Mais c'était un emploi temporaire.
L'entreprise lui a dit qu'elle pourrait passer
à un meilleur contrat, mais sans garantie.
C'était en automne 2011.
Tracy aimait cette entreprise, ses collègues
et le bureau se trouvait à moins de 10 minutes de chez elle.
Donc malgré une seconde offre d'emploi,
dans une autre entreprise, à un poste permanent,
elle a décidé de s'en tenir à son stage
en espérant que tout irait pour le mieux.
Elle a fini par surpasser toutes leurs attentes,
et l'entreprise ne lui a pas seulement offert un CDI,
début 2012,
mais ils l'ont rendu encore plus intéressant et stimulant,
parce qu'ils savaient que Tracy serait à la hauteur.
On avance jusqu'en 2015,
après la promotion de Tracy.
L'entreprise a payé ses cours du soir de MBA.
Elle a même embauché un autre redécolleur pour l'aider.
Le CDD de Tracy était une tentative,
tout comme un stage,
qui s'est fini brillamment pour Tracy et pour son employeur.
Mon rôle désormais et de faire adopter le concept de stages de réinsertion
par de plus en plus d'employeurs.
Mais en attendant,
si vous reprenez le travail après une césure,
n'hésitez pas à suggérer un stage ou un arrangement similaire
à un employeur qui n'aurait pas instauré de tels programmes.
Ce sera peut-être une première pour eux,
et vous servirez d'exemple à plus de redécolleurs.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)